bonjour à tous on va parler santé pour
les 12 minutes à venir seuil et ça
démarre merci avant en préambule en
toile la dit quand l'istec m'a contacté
et m'a dit voilà le sujet sera la tente
la tendance serait la médecine des
immortels je voulais juste avoir deux
remarques avec vous on ne parlera pas
aujourd'hui de jean d'ormesson
aux dernières nouvelles j'ai regardé les
infos juste avant il est pas mort et
l'ensemble des immortels de l'académie
française dans la moyenne d'âge doit
être de 78 ans vont bien aux dernières
nouvelles
donc j'ai vérifié sur google c'est pas
le sujet kristek voulait que je
développe aujourd'hui
l'autre sujet a déjà été abordé
si vous vous attendez je parle de
transhumanisme d'immortalité à lécher la
crémerie du docteur laurent alexandre il
a fait un thé dicks paris très
intéressant sur le sujet et c'est lui
qui maîtrise bien mieux ces sujets là
que moi donc maintenant en préparant
cette présentation j'ai beaucoup pensé à
mon père il était médecin généraliste
il est mort en 2006 et il avait 62 ans
comme quoi les cordonniers sont souvent
les plus mal les plus mal chaussés
j'ai beaucoup pensé à mon père ce que
j'aurais voulu vraiment savoir qu'est ce
qu'il aurait pensé de cette réflexion
sur l'immortalité de cette médecine des
immortels lui qui avait à l'âge de 4 ans
décidé de devenir médecin pour que sa
mère ma grand mère ne meurent jamais
alors il a plutôt réussi
parce que quand il est mort en 2006 ma
grand mère vivait encore donc peut-être
qu'il est parti avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli
elle est morte quelques années plus tard
mais en tout cas c'était sa vocation
décidé de faire en sorte que les gens
vivent le plus longtemps possible et le
mieux possible en préparant j'ai aussi
beaucoup pensé à mes enfants je suis
abonnée au time magazine et si vous le
lisez aussi il ya quelques jours on a eu
cette une du time magazine
ce bébé aujourd'hui les dernières études
monde qui pourra peut-être livres
jusqu'à 142 ans un boost avec
l'espérance de vie en france aujourd'hui
est de 85,4 ans pour une femme et 79 2
pour un homme
l'écart se réduit c'est la journée de la
femme demain mais il se trouve pour vous
rattrape mesdames ou en tout cas je sais
pas qui rattrape
et il augmente l'espérance de vie
augmente de trois mois tous les ans moi
quand j'entends cent quarante deux ans
je vous avoue que ça me laisse un petit
peu songeur je pense à au réchauffement
climatique au chômage aux retraites à
des ch à michel drucker qui sera encore
là dans son 42 ans le dimanche sur
france 2 j'avoue que ça me ça motive
moyens mais bon ce que je voulais
aborder avec vous dans ma présentation
aujourd'hui c'est ces deux questions la
première c'est comment est-ce qu'on en
est arrivé là à parler d'immortalité de
vie à 200 en 300 ans milan et surtout
cette question que sur laquelle je
travaille tous les jours c'est qu'ils me
soignera demain pour le faire comme tout
bon conteur j'ai décidé de lui ce que
j'ai à peu près huit minutes pour vous
raconter cette histoire de la
transformation digitale de la santé de
démarrer avec ce il était une fois en
anglais mais vous verrez pourquoi il est
en anglais puisque je vais partir d une
du times depuis quelques années pour
pouvoir aborder un certain nombre de
sujets il était une fois la génomique
je ne sais pas si vous avez vu il ya
quelques semaines le 20 janvier barack
obama faisait son discours de l'état de
l'union et il a lancé une nouvelle
initiative celle de la médecine de
précisions on sait qu'obama a toujours
été impliqué sur les questions médicales
avec l'obamacare et ainsi de suite mais
là où ça change énormément c'est qu'il a
annoncé un programme de séquençage
génomique de plus d'un million
d'américains et dans son discours et les
10 voilà ça peut marquer pour la pour
l'amérique la faim de maladies telles
que le diabète et le cancer c'est là
l'objectif
vous savez que il a fallu quasiment 15
ans pour séquencer le premier génome
pour le premier séquençage complet du
génome a été fait en 2003 le premier
séquençage complet d'un individu unique
a été fait en 2007
voyez c'est une science qui est quand
même relativement récente et pourtant
aujourd'hui on est en train de l'annoncé
d'ores et déjà que nous vous moi
devrions avoir notre génome séquencé
d'ici quelques années est disponible
pour pouvoir travailler sur la médecine
personnalisée et préventive
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà avec des
sociétés privées comme twenty show et
demi c'est quand c'est votre génome de
façon partielle pour moins de 100
dollars
et à voir les produits prédispositions
vous pourriez avoir pour certaines
maladies
pour pour pour l'avenir il était une
fois la transformation numérique
en 1976 il y avait deux petits jeunes au
fond de leur garage qui créer leur boîte
ça s'appelle apple ça existe encore et
aujourd'hui c'est un des acteurs qui
pèse dans la santé les années 80 ont
marqué l'arrivée de l'ordinateur dans
les foyers préparer le développement
d'internet qu'on a connu dans les années
90 on est passé dans les années 90 il a
fallu dix ans pour avoir 300 millions
d'internautes
il y en a plus de trois milliards
aujourd'hui 40% de la population
mondiale est connecté et la santé est un
domaine extrêmement important sur le
digital et je parlerai tout à l'heure de
l'arrivée de l'internet des objets il
était une fois l'iphone parce qu'une
fois qu'on avait passé ce cas de
l'internet ce cap du de la connexion
fixe en 2007 apple a lancé l'iphone et
et ce sous titre du times sérieusement
on est à court de mots pour pouvoir dire
tout le bien qu'on pense de ceux de cet
appareil là il est vrai que avec
l'iphone est arrivé un écosystème
complet il ya plus de cent mille
applications mobiles de santé de
bien-être aujourd'hui disponibles dans
le monde
or faire le tri l'attend et parfois un
petit peu compliqué mais arrive
maintenant l'ensemble des objets
connectés liés à la santé
on va pouvoir tout quantifier notre
activité notre sommeil nos paramètres
vitaux et là aussi ça va pouvoir
révolutionner complètement nos vies et
notre rapport à la santé et la réalité
c'est qu'on n'est plus jamais déconnecté
les études montrent qu on regarde notre
téléphone environ 200 fois par jour on a
même inventé un mot pour qualifier la
peur de perdre son téléphone la norme
aux phobies on en est un état où ou
aujourd'hui sur google par exemple
toutes les toutes les minutes
là pendant la minute que vous je vais
parler les 4 millions de recherches sur
google une sur vingt
concernant la santé on dit que 25% des
conversations sur les réseaux sociaux
concernent la santé la santé est au
coeur de la transformation numérique et
de la transformation digitale
alors le times a annoncé l'immortalité
pour 2045
c'était suite à une conférence avec un
responsable de google que revel qui est
l'un des gourous du transhumanisme l'un
des gourous de cette pensée qui veut qui
met en avant le progrès technologique
supérieures liées à la machine qui va un
jour dépasser l'humain et qui va se
reproduire et s'accélérer une
problématique qu'on voit depuis quelques
semaines abordés par des experts comme
stephen hawking comme bill gates qui
disent attention attention à queue à ce
que l'intelligence artificielle ne
dépasse pas la capacité humaine et nous
dépasse pas entièrement google art et
enfoncé le clou en septembre 2013 cette
une a été une sorte de pavé dans la mare
de la santé il traduisait deux choses la
première ça y est la santé allaient
connaître sa transformation sa
disruption comme disent les anglo saxons
comme l'a connue le commerce le voyage
la musique où tant d'autres industries
etc en plus les acteurs de demain de
l'instantané pas forcément avec les
acteurs historiques l'industrie
pharmaceutique les assureurs mais ces
fameux gaffe à google apple facebook
amazon qui rentrait dans ce domaine qui
pèse environ 10 à 18 % du pib des pays
qui touchent 100 % des populations etc
et qui leur ouvre des perspectives
extrêmement intéressante notamment pour
gérer grâce aux dates un de la médecine
personnalisée préventive et c'est
atteint c'est le nerf de la guerre
vous savez qu on en gère énormément 90%
des données qui sont présentes sur le
web aujourd'hui ont été mises sur les
deux dernières années ont produit 2,5
trillions d'opter chaque jour et
l'internet des objets dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure
va générer 44 mille milliards de
gigaoctets d'ici 2020 les données on en
a partout vous savez que la plus grande
je vais essayer de pas tomber
vous savez que la plus grande base de
données au monde de santé et française
la base de données sniiram qui est la
base de données de la sécurité sociale
est la plus grande base de données
mondiale
on a 1 2 milliards d'enregistrements
chaque année 500 millions d'actes
médicaux 11 millions
de d'hospitalisation pour 66 millions de
français pour rendez compte ce qu'on
pourrait faire en pouvant aller dans ses
bases pour essayer de comprendre les
pathologies les effets des médicaments
beaucoup ont dit que lors du médiator si
on avait eu accès à cette base on aurait
pu gagner en connaissances et en nombre
d'années d'informations de façon
extrêmement importante c'est donner je
vous entends me dit mon dieu nous les
français c'est très big brother je vais
pas développer cette partie là bien sûr
que la sécurité la confidentialité
particulièrement dans la santé sont
essentiels ce que je voudrais partager
avec vous ces notions qui m'est chère
celle du data for good
la donnée pour de bon ce que je stocke
sur moi ce quantified self que je vais
faire deux mois va me permettre de mieux
me comprendre de mieux mesurer de
pouvoir comprendre dans le futur un
certain nombre de choses à partir de ce
que j'aurai mesurer et c'est tata pour
le bien c'est à cette date a que je vais
partager avec d'autres et va me
permettre aussi d'augmenter la
connaissance et d'améliorer pas mal de
choses il était une fois angelina jolie
vous savez elle a annoncé cette double
mastectomie préventive parce qu'elle
était porteuse d'un gène muté qui la
rendait extrêmement prédisposés au
cancer du sein et au cancer des ovaires
sa mère elle même était morte à 56 ans
d'un cancer des ovaires
elle tend expliqué dans une lettre qui
s'appelle mon choix médical où elle a
expliqué effectivement qu'elle avait
pris l'initiative et décider de
minimiser opus les risques la concernant
et ça c'est le grand changement pour
voir avec la transformation digitale de
la santé c'est la place du patient qui
de plus en plus grâce à l'information de
dispose grâce à l'éducation qui est fait
demande à être un acteur complètement à
part entière du système de soin de ne
plus avoir avec le pas le médecin cette
relation paternaliste mais une relation
de partenariat d'autant plus que 2 il
est de plus en plus impliqué
économiquement dans les choix de santé
qui sont faits donc il veut réellement
pouvoir avoir son mot à dire sur la
gestion de sa santé pour conclure
effectivement tous les drivers et koné
économiques technologiques médicaux
faut qu'on est face à une perspective
extrêmement forte de progrès au niveau
médical une perspective extrêmement
forte au niveau du progrès de
l'espérance de vie
je sais pas si on ira vers l'immortalité
je sais pas d'ailleurs si elle est
souhaitable
ça pose un certain nombre d'autres
question de savoir comment est-ce qu'on
va gérer des populations extrêmement
importante comment est-ce qu'on va
occuper les gens jusqu'à l'âge de cent
quarante deux ans
on le voit depuis tout à l'heure il est
au probablement aussi important qu'ils
aient un certain nombre d'activités
mental psychique pour pouvoir tenir
toute cette année la simple la simple
santé physique n'est pas suffisante pour
ça et aussi il faudra faire en sorte que
ce soit pour un meilleur système de
soins plus égale plus accessible plus
juste pourquoi aujourd'hui un cadre à
une espérance de vie à 35 ans de 7 ans
supérieure à un ouvrier
pourquoi vous avez deux fois plus de
chances d'avoir un cancer dans le
nord-pas-de-calais qu'à paris et pour
conclure je vous dirai juste cette
citation de woody allen qui disait on
dit qu'il a emprunté à kafka l'éternité
c'est très long surtout vers la fin
merci